Hola Pues el canciller mexicano Marcelo
ebrard dio la bienvenida a las partes en
la conferencia Interamericana de
seguridad social que fue la sede del
acuerdo de Tlatelolco para la
proscripción de armas hicieron uso de la
palabra Pablo Beltrán por parte de la
delegación e insurgente y otipatiño de
la delegación gubernamental ambos
coincidieron en que es fundamental en
este segundo ciclo de diálogos acordar
la agenda definitiva de negociaciones
consolidar la participación de la
sociedad en este proceso de paz y crear
las bases para un cese al fuego
bilateral ya en sus intervenciones Pablo
Beltrán hizo énfasis en que debe
llevarse también alivio a las
comunidades que han padecido este
conflicto en Colombia y también a los
presos políticos por su parte otti
Patiño hizo énfasis en que este proceso
feminizarse dijo que es en las mujeres
donde encontrarán la fuerza para la paz
y también destacó la metodología que se
lleva a cabo y que consiste en que todo
lo que se acuerde en esta mesa tendrá
que implementarse en los territorios
porque la mesa dijo no es infalible será
en las comunidades donde terminará de
detallarse también ambas partes
reconocieron el apoyo de la comunidad
internacional de los países garantes y
de los países acompañantes así como de
la Iglesia Católica OTI Patiño también
destacó que se incorpora a esta mesa los
representantes de la Policía Nacional y
bueno la bienvenida el canciller Marcelo
ebrard dijo que México estaba muy
contento de recibir a estas partes en
negociación y que el único papel era
facilitar las condiciones para que
lleguen a un acuerdo ahí se llevarán a
cabo las negociaciones en este segundo
ciclo de conversaciones